Hey, Wisecrack.
Jared, here.
It all started when someone at the office
said, “Jared.
You gotta watch The Boss Baby.”
So, I did.
And then, perhaps reluctantly, we covered
it on our movie podcast, Show Me The Meaning!
And, yes, shameless plug —check it out
using the link in the description.
And let me tell you - something odd happens
to you when you spend hours thinking about
The Boss Baby.
Soon, it became a semi-ironic obsession.
And then, after it got nominated for an Oscar,
we said, “F**k it!
We have to do a video on The Boss Baby.”
So, we’re doing something a little different
today.
It’s not that The Boss Baby is a deliberate
and nuanced exploration of childhood psychology.
It’s more: holy shit, this movie accidentally
shows us how the way we currently think about
love is not only ruining us, but our future
children.
So, if you thought the Tide Pod challenge
was bad for kids, strap in for this Wisecrack
Edition on The Boss Baby.
And as always, and if you care: spoilers ahead.
Let’s start with a recap.
Tim is living a perfect childhood with his
family.
It’s nothing but imaginary adventures, and
expensively licensed lullabies — "Blackbird
singing in the dead of night.”
Until… the baby shows up.
Suddenly, Tim’s parents need to spread the
love around, and Tim finds himself struggling
with not being the center of attention.
“What about me?!”
Tim learns that this is no ordinary baby — it’s
an Oscar Nominated Boss Baby.
It can talk, hold meetings, and eat solid
food.
At first, Tim tries to expose the baby’s
bossy ways, thinking a besuited baby might
freak his parents out enough that they…
I dunno throw the baby away or something.
But the boss baby isn’t going out like that
and outwits Tim at every turn.
Tim learns the baby is only around to foil
Puppy Co.’s mysterious new puppy that threatens
to make babies obsolete, somehow.
So, he agrees to help.
Tim and the Oscar Nominated Boss Baby sneak
into Puppy Co. to conduct some corporate espionage.
Their madcap adventure goes off the rails,
and they end up in Las Vegas saving their
parents from a rocket ship with the help of
a tidal wave of puppies.
It’s weird.
So, what’s the movie really about?
Well, the short answer is easy.
It’s about love.
Tim wants his parents’ love, The Boss Baby
wants to win the market share of love back
from those gosh dang puppies, and the villain
wants to steal love away from babies.
"No one will ever want a baby ever, ever again!"
It all comes back to love.
In the end, Tim and The Boss Baby have a delightful
reunion when they realize that love is not
a finite resource; there’s enough for everyone.
Now, that’s a nice message and all, but
anyone who’s ever had a high school crush
knows we don’t always get the love we want.
Now, I know — who cares?
A silly kids’ movie has a reductive view
on love, so what?
Well, this view on love isn’t just simplistic.
Some might call it dangerous.
Like known weirdo, and everyone’s second
favorite psychoanalyst, Jacques Lacan.
One of Lacan’s fundamental ideas is the
idea of Lack.
In short, Lacan says that we spend our lives
looking for meaning, unity, and peace, but
those aren’t real things.
We’re never going to find them, and the
desperate search for them is what makes people
neurotic.
We develop social and psychological disorders
to cope with the fact that despite how badly
we want life to be perfect, it never will
be.
And it’s this lack that defines Tim’s
struggle in the film.
For Lacan, it all starts with a childhood
trauma called “the mirror stage.”
When we’re babies we don’t really know
what the hell is going on around us, but everything
is awesome.
We’re fed, we’re taken care of, and it’s
all good, but eventually we see ourselves
in a mirror and realize we’re not part of
a comfy, cozy world, but just one little being
in a giant world.
That realization hurts.
It’s when we realize we’re on our own.
We see this phenomenon play out in Boss Baby
too, albeit a little differently.
Tim is naive to the fact that the world doesn’t
cater to his every need until the Boss Baby
shows up, and he is traumatized.
Suddenly, the world isn’t all about Tim,
his parents only have a finite amount of love
to give —
“Mom and Dad don’t even know you!
They love me!”
“Oh, yeah?
Do the math, kid.
There is only so much love to go around.
It’s… like these beads: you used to have
all your parents love, all their time, all
their attention, you had all the beads…
but then I came along.
Babies take up a lot of time.
They need a lot of attention.
They get all the love.”
“We could share.”
“You obviously didn’t go to business school.”
This theory that there isn’t enough love
for everyone is the foundation of every Oscar-nominated
choice the Boss Baby makes.
Tim tries to live with the baby.
But he can’t — it f**kin’ sucks — so,
he tries to expose him, so his parents will
get rid of him.
No dice.
He even jumps over a train and sneaks onto
an Elvis-themed flight to Vegas, all to make
this baby go away.
Why?
Because the baby interrupted his notion of
how love works.
“Life was good.
Life was perfect.
But as I drifted off to sleep, something my
parents said got me thinking: where do babies
come from?”
No matter how much this feeling of having
your ideal reality shattered may suck, it’s
an essential stage of human development.
However, instead of having Tim move past this
difficult stage, the film doubles down on
his childish fantasy - suggesting that love,
is, in fact, infinite.
Tim writes a letter to the Boss Baby saying
that there’s plenty of love for both of
them, as long as they have each other.
It’s heartwarming.
But for Lacan, desire for love, or anything
else, is insatiable because the world will
never be perfect.
It is the inevitable outcome of lack.
We’ll never have the flawless, complete
life we want, so we focus on specific things
as objects of desires, or on individual problems
as the source of our suffering.
In other words, Tim’s idea that love can,
or should be, infinite, is a fantasy.
And boy, does Tim love fantasy.
Throughout the movie we see him creating fantasies
to represent the world around him.
He uses those fantasies to entertain himself,
to show his feelings, and to grapple with
with how love works.
In the end, we learn the whole movie is just
a story adult Tim is relaying to his daughter
to prepare her for a sibling on the way.
“Is that a true story, Daddy?”
“Well, sweetie, that’s how I remember
it!
But you know what I found out?”
“What?”
“There’s plenty of love for everyone.”
Lacan might say this poses a few issues.
By creating this bizarre narrative about a
ruthless corporate baby who threatens to close
on all the market share of love in his family
unit, Tim is essentially demonizing his little
brother to deal with the fact that love is
not, in fact, infinite.
But whether finite or not, we’re always
going to want more, and we’ll never get
all the love we want.
This targeting of a single cause for all our
problems is something that Lacanian scholars,
and also regular people, refer to as “scapegoating.”
In the case of the family, we develop neuroses
to cope with the feelings of isolation that
start with the mirror stage.
Or we fabricate a story about a giant corporation
of babies to justify hating our little brother.
We see the same thing happen with the villain
Francis Francis, formerly super colossal big
fat boss baby.
He becomes an evil psychopath and tries to
steal love from all babies, because his fantasy
of staying a baby forever is taken away from
him, and he blames all other babies.
This is what happens when we expect a perfect
world and don’t get what we want.
We act like babies.
But not necessarily the oscar-nominated kind.
And then Tim does quite possibly the most
irresponsible thing ever: he passes his fantasy,
and all the neurotic baggage that comes with
it, on to his daughter.
Inundating your daughter with the idea that
your basic desires will always be fulfilled
is… well, not great.
That will probably lead to some issues down
the line… like whatever happened to this
kid: “Dude, you’re blue collar as f**k,
like, get the f**k out of my face.
You make no money.
Look, what are you wearing?
You’re disgusting.”
So, what’s the deal?
Is it just that love is another one of the
many things we’re programmed to want, but
doomed to never get enough of?
“Not so fast,” Lacan might say.
There’s in fact a secret way around the
problem of love and fantasy, and it’s also
hidden in the Oscar Nominated story of The
Boss Baby.
What the movie’s ending gets right is that
the love between the brothers is the healthiest
relationship we see in the movie, but that’s
not because love is infinite.
Instead, it’s because love depends on showing
us how much we’re missing.
“You don’t even know what it’s like
to be a part of a family!”
“And you don’t know what it’s like to
have a job!”
Lacan famously referred to love as “to give
what one does not have.”
When we love someone, we reflect their Lack
back to them.
We show them what they are missing, and for
Lacan that confrontation with Lack is far
more psychologically curative than covering
over our desires with fantasies and scapegoats.
If we accept that definition of love, it’s
hard to argue that the brothers don’t live
up to it.
From the very beginning they’re positioned
not just as opposites, but as complementary.
Boss Baby is practical, but Tim is a dreamer.
The Boss Baby writes memos, Tim takes action.
Tim has experienced love and values it immensely.
Boss Baby has never been loved, and isn’t
too worried about it.
“I may look like a baby, but I was born
all grown up.”
“You never had someone to love you?”
“Well, you can’t miss what you never had.”
They each cover the other’s flaws and reflect
them back to each other in a way that helps
them both grow and save the day.
It’s the Boss Baby’s motivational skills
that keep Tim on his bike once he loses the
training wheels.
“The path to success is not a straight line,
Templeton, but rather a wild ride!”
And it’s Tim’s imagination that allows
them to defeat Francis Francis, in the end.
By showing the other what they’re missing,
and embodying those values, they help each
other grow into more well-rounded and healthy
individuals.
For Lacan love isn’t meant to fill the gaps
we feel in our lives.
The attempt to make life perfect is exactly
what leads to neurosis and pathology and all
kinds of other messy things.
Instead, love shows us what we’re missing
and makes it okay, because we see what is
missing in someone else.
Maybe it seems like we’re going a little
overboard on a movie about a baby who is,
somehow, paradoxically, a boss, but this is
an important lesson.
Real life is full of disappointment, and few,
if any, things live up to the world we imagine,
but that’s no reason to get depressed.
All you need to do is realize that things
aren’t gonna be perfect.
Not everyone gets nominated for an Oscar,
and once you see that imperfection reflected
in the world around you… it’s really not
so bad.
Thanks, Wisecrack.